son personnage de raisin il était
lui-même footballeur quand il était plus
jeune il est devenu entraîneur
et il voit en jb la possibilité de
réussite de quelque chose qu'il a
lui-même ratez pas tous les matins pour
tout de suite défi maintenant c'est pas
le moment de relâcher la pression il
faut que je sois prêt à tout sacrifier
ils ont tellement de points communs que
se forge une amie c'est bizarre entre
eux comme par exemple le matin courir
ensemble tout faire les entraînements
tous les deux ce qui est interdit
reda lui symbolise la nouvelle
génération doit coacher cette nouvelle
génération ouverte issus de la mixité
sociale beaucoup plus à l'écouté de ces
germes symbolise aussi le deuxième à
venir que jb peut avoir s'il échoue à
nouveau physiquement ça viendra c'est un
rôle qu'on a vraiment écrit pour reda
kateb de l' envie de tourner avec on a
eu des discussions avec mathieu
coscénariste on a vraiment créé ce
personnage qui finalement était un peu
la pierre angulaire de toutes les
intrigues moi ça n'a pas marché parce
que j'avais pas compris ce que j'ai donc
expliqué